I've been told to bounce out here and
say you ain't seen nothing yet very poor
English we say you haven't seen nothing
yet do we
in any event to present the next award a
lady who has starred in motion pictures
all over the world become an
accomplished photojournalist and is the
only lady I know who was on the cover of
Life as a photographer and subject miss
candy Bergen and with her look I know
that if you repeat adjectives you can
run them into the ground words like
talented gifted outstanding but with
this fella he runs them right up into
the sky the star of Brian's song and
Lady Sings the Blues mr. Billy Dee
Williams
well we're here to give the award for
the best achievement in cinematography
now without it there's no moving picture
in fact there's no such thing as a
moving picture the truth is that we're
really looking at still pictures more
than a thousand of them per minute we
have so few illusions left today let's
not destroy this one magic has been
honorable craft all the way back to
Merlin imagine if we get through the
dialog then let's honor it tonight the
nominees for best achievement in
cinematography are butterflies of free
Charles B lang cabaret Jeffery Unsworth
the Poseidon Adventure Harold E Stine
1776 Harry straddling jr. travels with
my aunt or Aunt Douglas Slocum and the
winner is the winner is Jeffery Unsworth
the camera
miss Marie sir Bearington
one of the great pleasures of working in
cabaret was working with a wonderful
cinematographer Jeffrey Unsworth he
regrets tonight very much he cannot be
here to accept this award but expresses
his gratitude for this for this great
honor thank you